what was your first date like with your
wife it was one could take over so
exactly that's what every woman says yet
when I tell this good so my wife had was
she basically told me that this other
guy was not her boyfriend so I asked her
about him and she said no he's not my
type
he's not my boyfriend he's never been my
boyfriend you're my type oh yeah it was
the first time she ever said that yeah
and I was like okay yeah so I think I
called it the day after and was like
okay so can we go out on like Tuesday
night she's like no okay oh just like no
reason just like now he's like no I'm
working I was like okay great well okay
I get it how about like Thursday no I'm
working
smells like this I have Monday off
yesterday we'll go out and I was like
this okay I think it worked
in hindsight it works yeah I'm excited
to work I think in the moment I was just
like kind of just taken aback like is
she crazy
yeah and I think I was drawn to that
definitely drawn to that but yeah and
then the first date we actually we
linked up during the day because she's
like I'm gonna go I'm gonna work tonight
but let's do something during the day I
was like add a date sexy right things
I've ever done
okay so we went to this like Vietnamese
restaurant and we ate and then they want
it to end so I was like what else could
I do what else could I do and she was
sitting there we were talking and we
were talking and she said to me can we
get the first kiss out of the way she
got like I'm feeling you and I'm telling
you right now if it's bad or if it's
wack I just want to go home and never
see me
we're still together yeah so it was good
[Applause]
your now she's your wife and after seven
years like this is the thing I don't get
and I could never date an actor because
I ain't seeing my man with some other
chick up on a film being like now it's
just for work like just go yeah that is
a different level of comfortable first
of all I am an artist and it is acting
sure as always 100% acting she just
never got weird about it you know and
she's always said she's always sick her
girlfriends to this day even to this day
will see me they see me make out with
Kobe on Stumptown and be like you know I
don't know how you do it I don't know
how you do it and she tells him the same
thing every time
look he's never given me a reason yeah
to doubt so absolutely I will not stop
talking until you subscribe to my
youtube channel that's right and I could
talk a lot seriously not gonna stop yep
still here not going anywhere I see you
don't walk away from this